reste à connaître le taux de
radioactivité enregistrés depuis la
catastrophe de tchernobyl et plus
précisément comment mesure qu'elle ait
le maximum en temps normal est ce que
l'on a constatée en france
explication jacques violer la
radioactivité contrôler ici au vésinet
dépend du type de radio éléments qui se
sont répandus dans l'atmosphère neutrons
rayons gamma iode radioactif et cetera
dans le cas de tchernobyl le problème
immédiat et celui de llyod qui se fixe
dans l'organisme humain pas d'autres
éléments en france selon les
spécialistes la radioactivité n'a jamais
dépassé 200 becquerels unité de mesure
par litre de lait ou tôt alors que l'
oms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
a fixé comme limite toujours sans danger
2000 becquerels depuis la radioactivité
décroît régulièrement pour revenir à des
taux normaux voisins de zéro lorsque le
nuage radioactif est redescendu des pays
scandinaves vers l'europe du sud
il a frôlé la france nous étions le 1er
mai souvenez vous une météo parfaite une
photo satellite avec une france dégage
et pas de pluie ce nuage radioactif
invisible n'a donc pas été lavé par des
pluies ce qui explique que très peu de
radioactivité soit redescendue
précipiter sur le sol dans les prairies
et les rivières
il y à une radioactivité je ne vous
donne pas de détails mais en gros par
à-coups dix fois plus forte que la
radioactivité normale c'est-à-dire pas
dangereuse véritablement mais on a
tellement l'habitude depuis une
génération de mentir sur ces sujets là
là l'information officielle je veux dire
que on ment même lorsqu on pourrait se
passer de mentir alors que ce ne serait
pas dangereux on pourrait le dire ces
choses là qu'est ce que vous réclamez
vous ai connu récemment une bonne
information
une véritable information